hey there moviegoers my name is ryan
right and i'm gerry I'm rzo welcome two
reasons to see trailer thon reviews
where we go beyond your typical trailer
reviews and what else are we going to
talk about well let's hang out and find
out alright guys so today on the show
we're going to be doing comedy movies
coming up soon a lot of movies check it
we're gonna do the hangover part 3 the
heat and owen wilson and vince vaughn
are gonna reunite for the internship i'm
excited i love comedy movies yes i do
like laughter so i'm laughing a lot do
you like laughing our zoom me three RZ
doesn't normally like movies but i know
that she can enjoy a comedy here and
there so i'm glad i have one on the show
today except the r-rated comedies that
give you nightmares anxiety but anyways
you know comedies to me are one of the
most impressive things when you get it
right and that's just trying to make
something for the whole world where
everyone has to laugh at the st. jokes
you know what i mean that's a challenge
right there and when a movie can pull
that off it's very very impressive it's
kind of you know underrated to when they
do that unless so now but people kind of
look at companies like oh you're just
making people laugh and it's easy to
mistake just how difficult yes one of
the hardest things to get right you know
I don't laugh easily at things so I'm
excited to watch these movies not really
actually oya because um I said watch the
hangover but on the other ones I don't
even know what they aren't equally as a
team oh that's why we're gonna want
that's why you have trailers perfect
interlude into the first one let's do
this here we go The Hangover Part three
people here we go all right this is
coming out fairly soon and I loved the
first one me too I deaf person was sort
of a magic
experience hey second one was all right
it was kind of like the hangover exactly
word for word but in Thailand but the
first one is great and you didn't see
the second one right no i didn't i
wanted to and then they're like a bunch
of other movies I want to see before
that men never gonna be on it yeah see
the second either that's okay you guys
have to know is it is exactly like the
first hangover but in Thailand and
there's also a monkey right there's a
monkey and a funny asian guy was his
name-o Kenjo check each in know yeah so
with this movie I've seen the trailer
already and I'm excited to watch it
because it looks like they're bringing
it back to that freshness of the first
one hat it doesn't look like it's gonna
be beat for beat like the hangover part
two I'm hoping that's the case because
it seems like they did Todd Phillips is
like all this was always going to be a
trilogy and from what I heard about the
second one it didn't really seem like
they had planned a trilogy yeah it sort
of seems like oh [ __ ] we gotta make
another one I put in Thailand and now I
think they've had enough time to think
about it but they can make the third one
really badass what's your worst hangover
experience one time I woke up hungover
and I was naked in a bed by myself and I
had no idea my dial that doesn't sound
like yeah I wasn't fun maybe I just was
pretty making love to the bed or
something you found your camera hours
later and it's just a bunch of pictures
of you sitting alone drinking a wine
bottle yeah I don't really have a great
hangover story the only time I was ever
marginally hungover was at Disneyland we
spent that Idaho wow that's full of the
happiest place on earth yeah yeah oh
yeah I remember that off because we're
responsible people that's right Ryan
with that in mind let's watch a trailer
for a lot of very irresponsible with us
yeah
out drinking problems if this is the
third time they're doing this some guys
just can't believe the fourth hangovers
gonna be about them like Alcoholics
Anonymous or something like that what's
right oh yeah oh yeah it's gonna stop
being a funny movie and just that
intense drama
you
Cassie I'm hungry mom I'm with a
customer she's rude nobody likes you
yeah keep your mouth shut that would be
looks funny III didn't watch it looks
better than part 2 already based off the
trailer yeah the adventure looks bigger
and yes I'm scene part2 so you don't
regret it too it looks like they got
some fresh joke some fresh material
looks like it doesn't just take place in
one place but they actually explore a
lot more territory well I was at stake
you know it's a much more monumental
story for these characters than just
take my brother up for a bachelor party
you know it's much more than we just got
hung over and something bad has happened
because of its a result of the incidents
that have occurred from getting hung
over prior yeah I know because you guys
remember that I wish 50 actors name the
asian guy yeah a connection honestly
while I was watching the trailer all I
could think about was I'm so excited to
go to Vegas and just make that movie
myself wow you want all that you know
maybe not like jumping off one of the
hotel buildings and singing i believe i
can fly but other than that I know
pretty much excited to just live life in
Vegas you know that's what's cool about
it cuz it does have that fun adventurous
feel it makes you want to know that we
want to put that trip today yes maybe
not go exactly according to file if you
want to have a great time and it looks
like it's gonna be one hell of a great
time I just feel bad for Justin Bartha
because it seems like every film they
find a way he's dug oh he's the guy he's
the park he's not you know I don't
remember who it was but the other week
someone told me that I remind them of
the guy with the beard and hangover that
was me oh woe is me you don't look
anything like Xavier yeah like it's
similar to his behavior I really got to
take that your friend Lee Cooper i met
helms and yours at yo valley cooper is
really attractive you know it's right
that I'm Bradley but it's interesting
about it as Bradley Cooper is the most
famous and respected one but they're
really making the lead actor the guy
with the beard got it in here he's at
galliford audience and kazakh up in
august i loved is a comedian who always
does a lot of stand-up routines on the
piano and I loved him before I saw the
hangover so when I saw him in the
hangover it was great and since that
movie has become like a superstar so I
can see why they're making in the main
focus you know it just looks like one
hell of a good time and it looks like
they they they know this the flaws of
the second one and I'm open this how
they improved upon it Plus now we get
the showdown between Zach Galifianakis
and the females Zach Galifianakis what
Melissa McCarthy oh yeah cuz they're
both fat and I'm not just so that's a
maybe a bit like beside girl the fat
girl from bridesmaids oh ok got it yeah
but yeah it seemed like lately they've
just taken her career and made her the
females i go knocking so that's pretty
much it yeah to see them showdowns gonna
be excellent there's always a random
animal in the movie yeah there's like oh
that's right it's a trademark living in
the first one first one was a tiger
tiger in this second let's see it's a
monkey the right hands and linky okay
got it so this one it's a giraffe that's
a good observation there's a baby pay
attention look at me Brian's consensus
the hangover part 3 looks like
one hell of a good time dang over part 3
looks like one hell of a good time yeah
this looks like one hell of an adventure
and I can't wait to party with the wolf
pack Jerry's consensus yeah hangover 3
looks like a good time and I'm gonna be
there to have a good day Jerry thinks
the hangover 3 looks like a good time
and he's gonna be there I'm excited for
the wolf pack again it looks like they
may have improved on some things are
Zeus consensus I'm gonna watch the
hangover 3 and then go to Vegas Ozzy's
gonna watch the hangover 3 and then go
to Vegas I feel like see this movie
because I feel like I'm gonna have a lot
of fun in the theater where I normally
don't like me and I'm going to leave the
movie with like a bunch of goodbye
positivity energy all right so it's more
for the next film peeps at that of
course being the heat you're not doing
without Chino robert de niro now this is
a Sandra Bullock and the big girl from
all bridesmaids Melissa Melissa McCarthy
she has a name by for our zoo I have to
break it down like that sorry this movie
is from the director of bridesmaids it's
all I pretty much know about it I'm
excited to see you Cassandra book is a
good actress and Melissa McCarthy is
really making her way into the movie
business and constantly gets respect for
almost every rule she does even though
it's always some fat obnoxious chicken
so I didn't know for even an identity
thief people creditor or a lobster do
something i I don't know much about this
film so can't really comment on it let's
watch the [ __ ] trailer
you
put the guns in the bag and slide it
over now I guess you and her kind of
engaged now huh what you just gave me a
ring
I'm gonna check that [ __ ] out I like
action buddy comedies and this director
clearly likes to make movies for females
I want to watch because it looks like it
has a fresh take on it it doesn't look
like some thats bombarded with action
but more focused on the comedy it's
great to see Sandra Bullock bring your
comedic chops again we all expect that
from Melissa McCarthy but the Sandra
Bullock has some strong comedic chops
yeah I hope it's good I'm not entirely
so bad like I've only seen bridesmaids
that I know is Paul feeds we're first
big comedy is great and it's usually
hard to follow up it seems like you know
you have liked zombieland which people
loved and then that guy's next movie
people weren't so hot about and it
happens a lot of comedies so I'm
cautiously optimistic I guess zombie man
was a different situation because that
was a huge high-concept plot and then he
brought it down to a much smaller scale
where is this they kind of intensified
the story even more because this is an
action movie as well so you got a lot
more elements at play here but from a
female perspective starting to females
what do you think that's okay like Jerry
said I wasn't completely sold on it but
it just looks like something I've kind
of seen before I'll see it but it's more
of a rental to me it's not something
that I would go to the theaters and see
but you know the opening scene was with
the black man that black man was like oh
fasho I'm gonna see this movie and then
I guess we've established and ours he
likes white man that's killin sorry it
doesn't look too promising it looks like
a good laugh but um I don't know if it's
something I invest my time in you know
it's rare i do agree with you it does
look familiar but there's something that
looks fresh at the same time so that's
why i'll check it out it seems like the
kind of thing that could get overly
sticky which kind of worried me because
i really like someone stick to be
wanting to watch it for two hours Ryan's
consensus the he looks like a fresh take
on an action comedy the heat looks like
a fresh take on an action comedy Melissa
McCarthy is a funny fat chick and Sandra
Bullock is a hot funny chick Jerry's
consensus I'm cautiously optimistic
about the heat sherry is cautiously
optimistic about the heat you know I
like Sandra Bullock I like Melissa
McCarthy for the most part I'm hoping
it's a good time and I always like to
see chicks kicking ass or Zeus consensus
it's cool um I'll see you I have time or
you'll see the movie if she has time
yeah I mean
if I have nothing else to do I guess
I'll go watch the heat next click is the
internship boy all right Vince Vaughn
Owen Wilson are back to get you seen
wedding crashers right yes damn seen one
re oh my god oh not see wedding bridal
in time we're gonna watch wedding
crashers that movie is [ __ ] hilarious
what do you mean why would you watch it
two guys wanting to bone chicks at
weddings your type of movie are XIV
Jesus Christ I've seen the trailer for
this does not look as good as wedding
crashers it doesn't even comes close to
being as good as wedding crashers I
don't think it wants to be wedding
crashers I know it doesn't but it there
seems to be a lack of energy and
enthusiasm that usually comes from these
two stars but Vince Vaughn ever since
wedding crashers has not made so many
great films same can be said for Owen
Wilson yes I'm hoping that there's
something in their chemistry that
reunites and brings them back to having
that fresh foot this is just a trailer I
mean I like both of those guys for some
reason there's something that when Vince
Vaughn is playing a semi dumb nice guy
it doesn't tend to work for some reason
like when he's doing his Vince Vaughn
thing where he's super sarcastic you
know sarcastic guy like in wedding
crashers that's when it seems to work
the most for me so I don't know I don't
know how much I by him in that kind of a
role the way I would buy even Owen
Wilson the neck yeah and essence wedding
crashers a Vince Vaughn has been more of
a box-office appeal than Owen Wilson has
so I know it Vince Vaughn is getting the
lead part in this one above Owen Wilson
do you know where they are I don't know
what you guys just said okay with that
in mind uh another guy we have the truth
that's why we're going to watch the
trailer so you can refresh you on who
Vince Vaughn is
you
one of the two you guys go and find the
programmer his name is Charles Xavier
he's a professor he's in a wheelchair
Charles Xavier will found me out Cyclops
row we're all here now come closer mom
Professor Xavier is a total yeah okay
that's the second time I've seen that
trailer it doesn't look like it's
getting any better I did actually
honestly the jokes look a little cheap
they all look rehashed only that's kind
of fresh about it is the concept of
having a movie take place at Google
which is an interesting concept but the
execution honestly doesn't appeal to me
at all the most appealing thing about
this trailer to me is the supporting
cast like I find myself I really laugh
at trailers that much looks like there's
no context for the jokes but the
supporting cast is what had me the most
amused in that trailer I don't know if
it's modern Owen Wilson just I don't
know there's only so much thinking
elevate you know these the guys in step
brothers no that's how will ferrell and
if you don't see john c reilly oh this
doesn't look too like appealing just
because i feel like i can be in the
movie you know what i mean like did you
see the cast they were like young
teenagers and I felt like I saw myself
having the capability of participating
in the movie and what's wrong with that
nothing but it was likeable it was an
eye-catching I wasn't anything different
it wasn't moving I don't know yeah I
guess the reason why they would do that
is because they're trying to get the
people who are a little bit older who
appeal to owen wilson and vince vaughn
and then the younger generation lose a
bunch of teens to the marketing content
makes sense i guess they have a good
marketing campaign going on people are
probably gonna check it out just cuz
it's them reuniting after the awesome
wedding crashers but truth be told none
of us really seem that interested in it
I feel like the coolest thing about this
movie it was a school why its consensus
the internship doesn't look like it'll
deliver the internship doesn't look like
it'll deliver yeah honestly I was
excited to hear they're reuniting but
after seeing what the footage are
offering us not so excited Jerry's
consensus yes right now I can kind of
take or leave the internship Jerry can
take her leave the intern
[ __ ] like it could be good it doesn't
look like anything particularly great in
either way it looks like it'll be
squarely okay bar Zeus consensus I
definitely don't think I'm saying a
living arzu definitely doesn't think
she's seeing the movie it just looks
like a waste of time on a friday night
alright guys thanks for checking out our
video why don't you go ahead scroll that
comment box and tell us your
anticipation or your anticipation for
these movies that are coming up and if
you want to check out our actual movie
review show once you click this link
right here for reasons to see and if you
want to see more trailer thong reviews
once you click the link right here and
last but not least if you want to get
updated every time a new review or
trailer thon is up so try right here you
see that see that yeah let's uh we go
much better now much better a little bit
of cleavage goes a long way remember
that I really don't remember that my mom
would tell me that all the time and you
know it really kind of know the proper
motherly advice is less is more les's
but more is also more you know the
internship would look better if it took
place in the porn industry on the
internet the porn industry can afford to
have interns oh yeah actually no it's
probably run entirely by interns you're
right yeah they can't afford to pay for
anything just show us your boobs RZ
you